[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur verließ
will heute gibt es auf meinem kanal
bratapfel in einem leckeren muss mantel
und einer lebkuchen soße morath mag
bratäpfel nicht so gerne weil er einfach
warme süße des herzens ich mag aber wir
mögen sie ganz gerne und deswegen gibt
es die heute für euch und außerdem haben
ganz ganz ganz viele schon gefragt wenn
die macht vom bratapfel den typischen
bratapfel könnt ihr mit diesem rezept
auch machen da kommt einfach die nuss
bildung nicht aus warum die sims kruste
aber ich finde so einfach ein bisschen
spektakulärer und leckere ich denke ich
mal die zutaten für den bratapfel
verwende ich 5 da habe ich jetzt die
sorte jonagold 75 gramm butter 100 gramm
haselnüsse 75 g zucker einen halben
teelöffel zimt 125 gramm atze bahn und
einige zimtstangen ich nehme jetzt
zuerst die äpfel und schäle sie
normalerweise wird ja beim bratapfel die
schale daran gelassen und dann packte
der apfel schön aber ich mache ist denn
los mantel und daher muss die schale weg
und bei den äpfeln ist jetzt im prinzip
nur wichtig dass wir die richtige sorte
wählt ich habe nämlich auch schon den
fehler gemacht und habe die falschen
apple genommen und die zerfallen beim
backen einfach zu sehr
also hier eignen sich jona gold oder
boskop oder zum beispiel cox orange ganz
gut aber so süße äpfel die ich halt so
gerne zum snack ist wie pink lady zum
beispiel die zerfallen einfach zu arg
erster übrigens auch zerfällt schmeckt
zwar lecker was zerfällt
[Musik]
und dann nehme ich einen apfel entkernt
und stechen jetzt hier innen das
kerngehäuse raus da mache ich es oft
auch so dass ich einfach noch ein
bisschen mehr ausstechen
dann habe ich eine größere öffnung und
das passt einfach mehr füllung rein
das könnte
[Musik]
aus den apfel schälen kann man übrigens
immer einen richtig tollen update e
machen dafür einfach in eine kanne mit
wasser geben aufkochen lassen und dann
könnte danach blieben noch gewürze
dazugeben
die zehn schnellsten sternanis ich mache
noch zitrone mit rein und klar später
noch so apothekerin
die mutter habe ich jetzt hier bereits
in einem topf zerlassen jetzt sind die
haselnüsse dran
die werde ich einfach ganz kurz malen
und dann mit dem zucker mit dem
vermischen
nämlich die äpfel und taucht sich hier
in die butter und benetzte einmal
komplett mit der butter und die gibt
natürlich den sensationellen guten
geschmack ab aber sorgt natürlich auch
als kleber zwischen abgrund nussschale
es war muss mantel
wenn ihr jetzt eine größere portion
macht und die äpfel länger herum legen
dann sollte diese auf jeden fall mit
zitronensaft beträufeln
damit sie nicht brauchen werden aber ich
verarbeite er nicht weiter deswegen muss
ich das nicht machen danach kommen sie
jetzt in die muss mischung
dann direkt in einer offen feste form
[Musik]
magnete ich einfach die übrigen
haselnüsse mit dem marzipan
das ist dann die leckerer füllung da
habe ich auch keine erste übrig
eigentlich würde ich jetzt auch noch die
butter untermischen
aber ich glaube die last immer weg dann
wirst wissen so viel
und jetzt einfach in fünf portionen
einteilen
und dann zu einer langen rolle formen
sap wird sozusagen und dann das zäpfchen
in die abstellung in den abwehrblock als
füllung
[Musik]
und dass es besser wird so ein bisschen
foto tragen
[Musik]
und jetzt habe ich hier noch die
zimtstangen und die habe ich bereits
halbiert
die kommen jetzt hier nach oben rein
sehen hat auch so ein bisschen aus wie
der apfel strom und so kommt jetzt der
bratapfel in den backofen und ich kann
ihnen der zwischenzeit schon mal die
lebkuchen soße machen
[Musik]
für die lebkuchen soße verwende ich 300
milliliter milch 200 milliliter sahne 30
gramm zucker eine prise salz einen
teelöffel lebkuchengewürz 2 eigelbe und
zehn gramm stärke ich nehme jetzt zuerst
die sahne und gibt sie in einen topf
gemeinsam mit der milch man kann die
lebkuchen soße im prinzip über dem
wasserbad machen oder einfach direkt im
topf im wasserbad hat halt den vorteil
dass nichts anbrennt
aber so kann man auch gut aufpassen
damit auch nichts anbrennt ich habe
jetzt hier schon die gewürze rein also
dass lebkuchengewürz salz zucker kommt
dazu dann die eigelbe und die stärke
also also im prinzip alles wird schön
bisschen eiweiß um die soße jetzt alle
zutaten gut vermischen
ich stelle jetzt dem herz auf geringe
stufe und höhere hierfür etwa fünf
minuten bis die sauce schön eindeckt
die soße ist jetzt schön eingedeckt und
die werde ich jetzt einmal durch ein
haarsieb durchstreifen damit eventuelle
klümpchen verschwinden und dann lasse
ich die soße abkühlen und so wäre die
kalte soßen zum warmen bratapfel
jetzt sind die bratäpfel fertig und die
lebkuchen soße ist auch schon fertig die
gebe ich jetzt hier auf dem teller und
stadtrat sowieso nicht probieren kommen
wird weil es was warmes und süßes ist
habe ich heute verstärkung von zwei
männern
heute probieren alex & co man muss also
zu sagen ihr seid ihr nur mit mir
befreundet und netten moral gern gestand
murat du wurdest leider ausgeschlossen
ich gebe euch jetzt den apfel weil die
anderen brauche ich zum fotografieren
und den hab ich beim füllen ausgesehen
auseinander
wollt ihr einmal bewiesen so groß gehe
natürlich ganz ehrlich sein jacket ich
weiß nicht ich glaub löffel und gabel
ok den stängel müsst ihr beiden hier
man muss hier noch so wie vielleicht von
der füllung vertrauen lebkuchen soße
[Gelächter]
und das ist kurz mit gut
die leg kurs ist auch okay wir also zu
machen and no empfohlen
ja und falls jetzt jemand kein morgen
man kann ja auch den master weglassen
und was andere schreiben füllen rosinen
würde ich auch ganz gut passen aber ich
glaube die meisten möglichkeiten muss
sie nicht mögen ihr aussehen muss die
schokolade
weil sie das rezept nach machen wollt
dann geht auf meinem blog auch cds - dog
days mich noch ein guter appetit
dankeschön
vielen dank fürs verkosten bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]
sally backt sich zurück in die
vergangenheit alte klassiker neu
interpretiert frankfurter kranz und
mokka torte
viel geschmack und leichte krems statt
schwere sahnetorten die einem dann im
magen liegen
alles andere als alt die kuchen der
kindheit
neuem gewand einfach so sonntag 16 uhr
bei vox